Explosions heard blast heard in Bandar
Abbas uh Chabahar in southern Iran and
uh that is sending oil prices higher
right now. Session highs here for the
oil market.
>> Well well well back again Donald Trump
strikes after all. Donald Trump did
truth and this is the last thing we've
seen on Truth Social about Iran. Donald
Trump did truth this Breitbart news
piece eight hours ago. Trump vows to hit
back hard after first exchange of fire
with Iranians in weeks. Now, what's
unfortunate about this obviously is oil
prices are rising on this, but it comes
right after we're seeing that two super
oil tankers ended up getting struck in
the straight of Hormuz yesterday. Now,
this is part of the secret operation
that's going on. it's not so secret, but
the operation that's going on to uh
export oil out of uh of of the straight
of Hormuz. And so now apparently
following the disaster of apparently
MLRS launches to lay mines in the
straight of Hormuz were attacked by the
United States and then Iran
counterattacked by attacking bases in
Jordan with drones and uh ballistic
missiles. eight to 13 of them. Donald
Trump vowed to counterattack. We really
didn't get anything for about the last
24 hours. And now it seems the strikes
after potential coordination or
preparation or research or whatever have
officially occurred or are presently
occurring with blasts being heard in the
uh southern portion of Iran. We were
just looking I'm trying to pull it up
right here. We were just looking at
different uh areas inside of that region
uh to see where potentially these
strikes could be occurring. And then we
have a little bit of color on the super
tankers that were attacked just
yesterday. Uh but if we look over here
uh we could see this is the Bondar Abbas
area uh or city and region and uh we
explored this area just a little bit.
You could see the island of Hormuz is
here. Lorac is right here and then this
is Oman. This becomes very important by
the way for when we go through and think
how are these secret and night
operations being conducted and how are
these super tankers getting attacked.
Two of them we'll talk again about those
in just a moment. Two of them were hit
by projectiles and these are you know
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
cargo oil. The super tankers themselves
have massive value. Uh but when we look
at this map, what we want to remember is
that the southern shipping lanes are
right here, understandably to the south
along the Omani coast. One of the super
tankers was apparently struck just
norththeast of Casab right here. So
presumably in this region right here, if
we were to pin it and you could see that
the strikes uh that well where the super
tankers were hit were in this shipping
lane here. The Telegraph reports that
there's an evening covert operation to
bring ships through two shipping lanes
along the south here. One inbound lane
and one outbound lane. Uh and you can
see the strikes uh occurred here or are
presently occurring in Bondara Abos. Now
this region is interesting because is
right here in the critical choke point
of the straight of Hormuz. This is Lark
Island, which is really where Iran wants
ships to go through. Iran wants ships to
go through this shipping lane here so
they could toll them and inspect them or
whatever.
It is presumable that the port of Bondar
Abbas hosts the customs offices for
actually tolling uh the ships that pass
through here and maybe as a result they
have become a target. Now, we don't know
exactly where the strikes have occurred,
but here are some things that we do
know. We do know that right here there
is a national Iranian oil products
distribution company. You could clearly
see the oil storage right here. And so
oil exits the port from here as it's
piped over here or trucked over here and
stored here until it could board an
actual ship. You can also see a lot of
various different vessels collect
containers over here, multistacked
uh in this port. So clearly a very
active port. We've got government
offices throughout various different
components that we've seen, at least
what's labeled here. For example, right
here. This is a government office right
here. We did also search one of the
translations for some of these buildings
right here. And uh what we searched when
we translated the name of these
buildings right here came up right here.
I wrote translate
to sat bandari boner translate this uh
to freedom is what I wrote. So I wrote
translate to freedom and the AI said now
translating from Persian to English and
apparently it is a harbor facility. But
anyway when we explore this area it it
does seem like it would be ripe for
disruption by the United States given
that we do have customs offices here. We
have oil offices here. We clearly have a
port. Uh we also have a helellipad right
here uh at the roundabout. These I
believe were government offices right
here as well. Military residents. See
military residents right here. So there
are clearly some high value targets that
like I could literally target with
Google Maps. Obviously, you know, who
knows? There could be some misdirection
and misleading. And I hope the US
military has better intelligence than me
just on Google Maps. But the point is
this is apparently the area that is now
uh being struck. We're just getting
reports of explosions. Uh this is uh
we're getting Axios is reporting this.
I'm just this is really now just coming
through the wire services. Uh here on
the wire services, US striking targets
around straight of Hormuz. Uh we also
have uh fear of oil rising even more.
And and then of course this comes on the
back of what we had with uh the oil
tankers that got struck overnight. So
let me just go through that and then
we'll look at some more color on this.
Also uh quick reminder if you want to
get some of the notes we leave on this
totally for free. You could go download
the Meet Kevin app and get our notes on
our research for free. Download the Meet
Kevin app by typing in Meet Kevin in the
Apple or Android app store. Once you
sign up, if you're a course member, make
sure you use your same course member
email address. Remember, we did extend
the coupon to Friday due that glitch
that happened on coupon expiration
night. After you sign up, use that same
email if you're a course member.
Otherwise, you can sign in with Gmail,
whatever is easier for you. You can
actually also use the web app at
app.mec.com and you can see some of the
notes uh and and research that we post
uh for free. But, uh let's understand
what happened with these oil tankers. So
looking at this these shipping lanes
here last night uh two oil tankers were
struck that were carrying Saudi Arabian
crude oil. So this is Saudi Arabia right
here. So you would anticipate that
potentially uh through you know a port
through Qatar or even a port coming out
of Saudi Arabia oil tankers are going to
get loaded up and they'll be in route.
they can now, according to the
telegraph, register with the US military
and actually get sort of this security
escort uh through the southern shipping
lanes here. Now, previously, Sentcom has
denied that they do this, but apparently
it happens pretty regularly. This is
probably why Donald Trump says that uh
oil is flowing really well through the
straight of Hormuz because US
the US military in coordination with the
blockade that we have are is essentially
conducting covert nightly escort
operations. It's estimated that
potentially 15 to 20 tankers can
actually go through the southern transit
uh channel along the Omani coast
protected by US fighter jets,
helicopters, and vessels every single
night. And apparently this has been
happening since late May, which was
roughly around the last time Sentcom
denied that they were providing this
sort of security. But this suggests that
since two oil tankers were struck last
night, it kind of suggests that there
was a little bit of a security failure
that happened last night, it's possible
that the Iranians were sort of passively
allowing these nightly operations to
happen while there were positive
negotiations going on. Or it's possible
the Iranians just got lucky. You know,
maybe they're blind yolo launching uh
drones or rockets hoping to hit a ship.
Uh some of times they get shot down.
Apparently, there was some form of
failure yesterday where two ships ended
up getting struck. This is not good
because it just creates more fear in
that region. Literally yesterday,
Sentcom was denying that uh ships had
been hit. Now, this could be true
because of the timing of it. See,
yesterday claim Iran's IRGC claims that
a super tanker passing through the
southern route of the straight of Hormuz
struck two mines and was brought to a
complete stop. This is false. No ships
have been hit by mines. This is yet
another attempt to pass disinformation.
And then yet literally
shortly after that, two tankers hit in
Hormuz. And so we see two oil super
tempersh tankers attempting to exit the
straight of Hormuz were struck in quick
succession by projectiles yesterday. uh
one Liberian flagged tanker known as the
Seneagal Prosperity which is run by a
South Korean group uh was hit by three
rockets and a Saudi flagged ship uh run
by the Saudi company Bari was hit
multiple times just 8 minutes before
that. So clearly some form of security
failure in this escort happened which
could lead to fewer shipping attempts
going through this covert operation now
since it's not very covert anymore.
These ships usually go through with
their transponders off to make it harder
for the Iranians to track them. That
also sort of lowers the like official
counts of ships that have made it
through Hummus uh every single night.
That sort of gets reported online or in
social media or otherwise. But uh
apparently uh these strikes are uh in
retaliation for Iran's
um attack on the Jordan bases
which you know is now you know which was
retaliation for our strikes on their
mine laying launchers. These strikes are
now being called sort of defensive
retaliation.
Okay. Uh there's also coverage now
multiple reports in Bondar Abbas. Iran
has begun uh begun emerging over that
have been emerging from Iran over the
last several minutes. This includes a
visible US Air Force presence of KC130s
appear to be appearing to be departing
the area after providing fuel. This is
interesting. OA defenders got little
post here indicating uh KC130s for
refueling operations and sort of some
some of their flight paths over here. So
potentially conducting refueling
operations here right around uh the UAE
and Oman
and enabling potential fighter jet
strikes here. Not great. Uh obviously
not great because it's an escalation of
this issue. Uh multiple reports again of
explosions uh in Bondar Boss. Some talk
that maybe other areas are getting
struck right now, but right now we just
see Bondar Boss. Uh this comes at the
same moment that we're getting more
reports that Germany is connecting
Russia to the drone incidents that
they've had at airports and power
stations, which is really a test of
Russia sort of probing NATO. Uh and it
shows us the escalation of this conflict
really into a more global situation,
especially since right now you've got
the Iranian delegation meeting Chinese
and Russian leaders, which is the first
time that all three of them have met
face to face conveniently while the G20
is going on since this USIsraeli war
started uh on February 28th.
All not good. Now, the Telegraph reports
that potentially 15 me million barrels
of oil secretly transit Hormuz at night.
The Wall Street Journal doubts this.
They think it might be 10 million, but
it could be less. That the United States
government has an incentive to sort of
inflate some of these numbers, which
also makes sense. And US Sentcom has
tweeted that today at 12:00 p.m.
Eastern, so about 40 minutes ago, US
forces began striking Islamic
Revolutionary Guard targets in Iran. The
strikes follow a recent attempted attack
by the IRGC against commercial shipping
in the straight of Hormuz. That's
probably the mind laying uh event, but
also the two ships that were struck
yesterday. So, this is sort of uh you
know a middle finger for for those
attacks, if you will. Uh the poly or the
kalshi odds of an of a US Iran nuclear
deal before 2029 have now plummeted to
just 27%.
uh which is quite interesting because uh
the odds of a deal before March 1st 2027
have fallen to 8%. Uh and so we could
see some of the uh reduced odds for hope
in the region which is obviously driving
up inflationary concerns driving up uh
oil futures uh oil Brent now jumping to
$94.
That's up from the 92 that we had this
morning which is not great. Somebody in
the chat here says, "Places for you says
security escorts cost about $50 to $90
million per vessel." Wow. Uh that's
pricey. Uh at the same time, the United
States is trying to
uh promote this idea that hey, we're
going to be able to get oil from other
places. You can see that the Reinvest
wire service here, you can get that for
free in that Mecan app, which I've got
up here on the banner. Uh you can see
this indicates the US officials are
talking about Chevron announcing
expanding operations in Venezuela and
Secretary Wright is heading to Venezuela
tonight to sign oil deals. This of
course a way to try to mitigate some of
the damage that's happening in Iran
given that this conflict uh continues to
unfortunately escalate. You can see here
Alazer indicating that uh Iran believes
the United States is stuck in a Middle
East quagmire. It has become clear they
are now stuck in a massive error they
have made and it's their usual habit to
raise excessive demands. In each
occasion they fall into a state of
miscalculation. We cannot accept any
orders being dictated upon us. If they
continue with this philosophy they will
not get any different result. Some other
highlights that we have on the Alazer
notes here and there is a lot about
attacks inside of uh Gaza and conflict
between the uh Palestinians, Hamas and
Israel. But focusing just on Iran here,
Iran's president thinks thanks Putin for
Russia's backing uh in the war. Some
other highlights we have here include
this is here. This is the first time
Iranian, Chinese, and Russian leaders
have been able to meet face to face
since the start of the war. We mentioned
that already. White House officials tell
Al Jazzer that Iran wants to make a
deal, right? They want to make a deal.
Don't mind us bombing them and them
attacking us. Keep in mind, they have
also argued, Iran has argued that
they're going to strike us uh more if we
strike them. We just struck them. So now
we're waiting for the Iranian
retaliation. Right.
US official now reporting that we want
to see legitimate oil industry in
Venezuela. Right. Of course you do. Now
that Iran is turning into a disaster,
uh, we have made the enemy conclude that
it cannot stop our missiles, says Iran.
I mean, in fairness, yesterday's strike
against two of our vessels was either a
security failure or the Iranians were
getting better. Galibbuff, who's a
little bit more of the military hawk
over in Iran since you have sort of the
hawks and the doves. The president is a
little more doubbish. Glly is a little
bit more hawkish, although less hawkish,
less hawkish than even some of the most
extreme in Iran. Galibba says, "The
enemy should know that in the next
rounds of war, we will have greater
superiority in both quality and
quantity." Basically saying, "Hey, we
got more rockets and we got better
rockets." Well, probably. I mean, they
keep getting shipments from China and
Russia. I mean, who knows what's in
those shipments. It's would it certainly
wouldn't be bombs.
America wants to use the southern route
of the straight of Hormuz in violation
of the memorandum of understanding and
we will not allow it. Galibbah has
acknowledged that the enemy has managed
to get some ships through the Hormuz but
argues that Iran remains in complete
control of Hormuz. You know, Besson
obviously downplaying how important
Hormuz is. In the future, Hormuz in
fairness won't be very important because
we're going to pipeline around it. We
have, you know, a lot actually I have a
sheet somewhere around here. It actually
might be right under this about So,
yeah, it is about some of the
alternatives that we have. The problem
is, even though Besson is really excited
about us being able to utilize
alternatives, we have to remember these
are going to take time. So, we have some
potential short-term solutions,
medium-term solutions, and long-term
solutions. You could screenshot this or
you could also see it in the Meet Kevin
app. uh short-term pipelines, trucking,
transponders off, nightly transiting,
longer term, a west pipeline in the UAE
to get past and under sort of uh the
straight of Hormuz. Uh a port below the
straight of Hormuz. uh and that would be
on uh the Gulf of Oman side of the
straight of Hormuz as well as then
pipelines to the Mediterranean and uh
multiple other pipeline projects that
are expected to be uh deployed as well
as increased funding for the region. I
mean all of that is entirely reasonable
but for now they've got an upper hand on
us.
Now continuing here, Bessant dismissed
the importance of Hormuz, saying the
increased use of pipelines will make
Hormuz irrelevant. And Bloomberg aptly
says here, "The common appeared not to
take into account the time it would take
to switch supply routes." Correct.
US will announce new sanctions on anyone
that does business with the IRGC.
Galibbuff says the US naval blockade
against Iran amounts to a military act
and that Tran will respond accordingly.
Uh we have uh the US Galibbuff says that
if the US does not want anybody to
export oil from the Gulf, no one will be
able to. That is the claim they are
making. And if we look at some of the
latest here, US says it is striking
targets in Iran
and explosions heard east east of Bondor
Abas. Now that's interesting east
because the port is on the west side.
Five more explosions were heard around
the village of Masan
and four explosions were also heard in
Keshum. Okay, so it sounds like multiple
areas have been hit. The east side of
Bondara Boss and we don't know that this
is inclusive of of all of the striking,
but the east side of Bondara Boss is uh
never eat soggy waffles over here, which
would be where the airport is. But you
also have I mean this looks more like a
monument pier, but it's possible there
are just some military installations out
here. We don't particularly know like
what is this? Uh this doesn't even have
a label. It just says building. Yeah, I
mean that that would be a potential ripe
target if it ends up being some form of
military installation. Does seem like it
has some form of uh fencing at least
around part of it. So, we don't know. Uh
this is speculation of course, but you
do have the airport on the east side.
The west side has the port. If we look
at MSAN, a village
uh no not Vietnam, Iran.
There we go. Uh, this is
supposedly where some strikes are being
conducted. That's pretty far away. I
don't know if that's accurate. And let's
see what else Alazer is reporting here.
It could also just be This is in Keshum.
Keshum. Okay, that's just a region in
Keshum. That's probably why. So, if we
go to Keshum, that's going to be here.
And, uh, this is also
where we want ships or this is where
Iran wants ships to go through, where
the United States does not want ships to
go through. So various different regions
on this island uh appear to be getting
struck. So this this theater right
around Hormuz is where explosions are
being heard.
Uh Masan, let's see if I can find that.
Masan Keshum.
I don't know if
the spelling of the regions is screwing
us up over here, but these are some of
the parts. There we go. Messen. Maybe a
different spelling. That would be the
lower portion over here. Ah, well,
interesting. Seems like they have a
protected sort of port here as well. Ah,
look at this. This is where you seem to
have possibly a lot of these sort of
fastboats.
That's been another target by the United
States is fastboats have been not only
spies for helping locate ships,
especially when these nightly covert
operations are being done. If you don't
have the radar installations, maybe you
could just, you know, utilize fishermen
with radios, right? Uh so a more
primitive uh method of intelligence
gathering. And this particular area OP
also happens to be uh let's see what
else we got here that those are mosques.
Uh no, I don't see any government
buildings. I thought maybe there might
be some government buildings. It's I
mean they're obviously not all going to
be labeled, but that is interesting that
this area is just another port, which is
a perfect spot. That's almost the
closest spot to launch a fast boat from
to uh to intersect the the southern
shipping lane over here. That's almost
the the most short or the shortest
route. Very interesting. So, uh strikes
are back. So, this conflict is
unfortunately evolving. What does this
mean for us? Well, as usual, it means
oil higher for longer. Typically, yes.
Uh oil uh fluctuations and geopolitical
strife is a buy the dip.
That is generally the case.
Unfortunately, the downside of how long
this is going is you also have to
balance your dip buying with how long
can the camel of the United States
economy hold the weight of circular AI
financing, geopolitical strife, high
rates, high rates end up affecting the
AI market. So while geopolitical can be
the by a buy the dip, we also want to
balance that with how much exposure do
you really want to stocks in the event,
you know, there's a slowdown in
artificial intelligence that potentially
is even driven by more expensive funding
costs due to to the war in Iran. So
overall, I maintain cautious dip buying
uh is an appropriate strategy and sort
of level-headed and measured. But you
can see after these strikes started uh
you did see the market really start
slowing down. Seems like maybe after the
initial reports the NASDAQ uh 100 really
just sort of continued its its uh dell
here. Although Monero really holding up
today 5.5% and so is Apple at nearly 3%.
Really impressive.
>> Why not advertise these things that you
told us here? I feel like nobody else
knows about this.
>> We'll we'll try a little advertising and
see how it goes.
>> Congratulations man. You have done so
much. People love you. People look up to
you. Kevin Pafra there, financial
analyst and YouTuber. Meet Kevin. Always
great to get your take.